-James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-I guess he melted.
-It's beautiful.
Thank you, this season of
"The Bachelorette,"
for having two Bachelorettes,
which sounds crazy
until you realize it also has
two Justins, two Jareds,
and 38 Jordan R's.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I'm Jordan R.
I'm an entrepreneur."
Thank you, "The Gray Man," for
being a new Netflix thriller
about two men fighting to
the death over whether
it's spelled
G-R-A-Y or G-R-E-Y.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Are you from England?"
If you're from the U.K.
Thank you, eating s'mores around
a campfire, for making sure
I'm nowhere near a sink or
a napkin after holding
the stickiest food ever made.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Rub dirt.
-Rub dirt on it?
-I don't know.
-Thank you, Delta Airlines
flight that blew out two tires
while landing at LAX,
or as Spirit Airlines put,
"See, that's what you get for
having planes with wheels."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Don't want to say I told you so.
Thank you, air conditioners and
Hot Pockets, for being two ways
to keep things cold
on the inside
when it's hot on the outside.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Just keep eating it.
It'll cool off.
Thank you, popsicles, for making
your 7-year-old look like
they just took down
a bottle of Merlot.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you, string cheese,
for looking like mozzarella
sticks at a nude beach.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my thank-you notes.